Hello, we're old. It's Haraj.
And welcome to this live session.
Today we're going to be talking about
the differentiable neural computer.
Just, I mean, just take a second to just
soak in how awesome that name is. I mean,
this is, this is a really,
really cool model. It,
it came out of deep mind a few months
ago and it is the successor to the neural
Turing machine.
So recall from my last weekly video,
we talked about metal learning or learning
to learn the edge of deep learning
and, and future directions that
we should move. So this is like,
this is a relatively complex model.
Uh,
and it's definitely the coolest
model that I've ever seen and I've,
I've really had a lot of, it was,
it was really fun studying this,
this thing because it gave me so many
ideas of directions we should move and
things we can do with this.
But let's talk about the problem here.
And the problem is how do we create
more general purpose learning machines?
And that was the problem with which they
designed this, this, uh, this model. Okay.
So I'm going to show you guys what the
demo is for this and I'm going to then
talk about what other things we
could do with this. But before we,
before we do that, let me answer
some questions. All right,
so to start off with,
go ahead and ask some questions while
I explain a little bit more about this.
Okay. And then I'll look back at
questions through slack. Okay. So
neural networks are great, right? We've,
we do a bunch of amazing
things with that with them.
But the problem with neural networks are,
are that they are made to focus on a
single task or whatever you train it on,
right? You can take a neural network
and you can train it to, you know,
learn to recognize cat,
you know, cats in images,
but then you can't take that same neural
network and then ask it questions about
the London subway or the best path to
take, uh, two from point a to point B.
You just can't do that.
But what if you could,
and how would you design a system
like that? So that is what the DNC is,
is it is,
it is a neural network with an
external memory store. So it's,
so it's got two parts.
You've got the controller,
which is a normal neural network.
You could use a feed forward net,
you could use recurrent net, you could
use any kind of network you want.
And in this thing,
this example,
we're gonna be using a feed
forward neural network.
And then you've got the memory bank and
the memory bank is an external matrix
and the controller interacts
with the memory bank by,
by performing a series of
read and write operations.
So we call these heads,
we end right heads.
So it takes an input it up, it, it
propagates it through the network.
And simultaneously it's reading and
writing to the matrix to learn about,
to both, right, what it's learned and
then read from the past time steps, what,
what it can use to then
make the output prediction.
And then it outputs the prediction,
right? So that's the basic idea.
And what we're going to do in
this example is we're going to,
let me see if I have the output somewhere.
The output is to basically map.
So here's the output.
I know you guys like seeing the output,
which is a definitely a good thing.
And so here's what it
looks like when I ran this.
We have two sets of numbers, right?
Zero is just one hot and coded vectors.
So zero one zero, zero,
zero that's the input.
And then one zero zero zero one zero,
zero and then we want to learn
the mapping between the two.
So then given some input,
we'll know the output, right?
So it's just binary mapping,
which is a very simple use case,
which is what we need for this model
because the model itself is where the
learning should occur.
But let me show you what they used it for,
which what deepmind use it for.
Okay, so this is what it looks like.
So you have your inputs and your outputs
and it learns the mapping between the
two, right? [inaudible] right. We,
that would in my build a neural
net in four minutes video,
same exact idea except a
way more amazing model.
So what they did,
and let's talk about what they did first.
What deepmind did is they said,
okay,
let's apply this to the
London Underground. Okay.
And right.
So the questions are coming in.
So let me answer two questions
and then let me go back to what,
what I was just talking about.
Question number one,
does it learn and predict
the hyper parameters? No. Uh,
that that is hyper parameter optimization
and it can be added onto this.
And the second question is,
uh,
can we do image recognition
with this? Yes. Oh,
and then one more question.
What's the difference between
this and the neural train machine?
I'll get right to that in a
second. Okay. So back to this,
what they did was they applied it to
the London Underground. Okay? So what,
what do I mean by this?
Basically the first thing they did was
they generated all these like random
graphs, right? This is a graph
problem. It's a graph problem, right?
Subway systems are all graphs. They
have nodes. And they're all connected.
And what they did was they gave it
a set of graphs and they had these
handcrafted, uh, inputs,
right? So they would say,
so this graph resembled some generated
subway and then it had a set of labels.
So it was a supervised learning problem,
right?
So they had this generated graph or
subway and then it's associated labels.
And the labels would be that the different
paths that you could take from point
a to point B. So you could go through
Oxford circus and taught them hands,
whatever, and in central whatever. So
that's what they did. And then one,
once they kept training it on
these randomly generated graphs,
then they gave it the
actual London Underground,
a graph with its associated pairs.
And it learned to then if you,
if you asked if you, if
you then said, you know,
two points like point a and point B,
it would tell you the optimal path to
get there because it had been training on
that. But here's where it gets even. So
Norman, so you could, you could do that.
Normally you, you wouldn't need an
external memory store to do that.
You could do that with a recurrent
network and LSTM network.
But what was really cool then was
they added something else onto this.
They added a question answering system.
So not only did they train it on
the London Underground's paths,
but they also added a
natural language to it.
So they train at first on
randomly generated graphs,
then they train it on a
text database where the,
where it was a question answer database,
um,
and it learned to associate a questions
with what they're associated answers and
then an associated both. So then you
could then ask it, hey, we, you know,
in natural language, like a
query, what's the best place to,
what's the best way to get from point
a to point B in natural language?
And then because it had this external
memory store that had the previous
learnings from the generator graph,
it could then apply those to
the natural language questions.
So you see these two entirely
different data types,
these two entirely different datasets
that this thing was able to train on.
So it w it learned to optimize for one
dataset and then it learns to optimize
for the next dataset and it
could associate between the two,
which is the cool part.
And you could then extrapolate this
kind of thinking to anything really.
You could train it on some set of
images and their associated labels.
And then something entirely
unrelated like you know, uh,
also a question to answer dataset.
So you could learn natural language and
then also maybe an audio data set so it
could learn the labels for audio. So
then you could ask it things like, hey,
what kind of sound does this cap make?
So it would see the cat picture and then
it would associate a sound with it and
it's got the language.
So it's like this general purpose idea.
Now it's not perfect, it's not Agi,
but it's a step in that direction,
which is very cool. And they
called it a computer, right?
Why do they call it a computer? Will
recall that computers, computers are,
they have two parts. They have a processor
and then they have memory, right?
You have your CPU and then you've
got ram random access memory.
And so what happens little, you know,
colonel level talk for a second. What,
what's happening at the kernel level.
Every time you're doing anything
on the computer is you the,
the Ram preloads a bunch of instructions.
And then each instruction is fed
to the CPU a one step at a time.
And what the CPU does is it takes in an
instruction, decodes it, executes it,
and then repeats the process. And this
process is called the instruction cycle.
And it is the hallmark of how computing
works, right? And then there's the GPU,
but that's a different story.
We're talking about the CPU. Now,
von Neumann architecture and computer
science was his very famous, right?
And a lot of computing is based
off of that idea. But what this is,
and now this is not deep mind talking.
This is Saroj talking. Uh, or this is,
this is my, this is, this is
my w what, what should happen?
We can use this as a framework for
building hardware as well, right? So it's,
it's a computer, but it's,
it's, it's all software.
There's no hardware associated with it.
But if we,
if we switch our thinking from serially,
uh,
decoding these instructions and instead
learning from instructions at the kernel
level, at the hardware level, then we
can get some really interesting results.
Now there are people working on this,
uh,
but I think it's really cool
to think about what the next,
the successor to both von Neumann
architecture is and also the successor to
silicon and what new mediums we
could use for computing could be.
So it's a lot of very exciting possibility
with just this, uh, architecture,
the software architecture.
Okay.
And let me show you guys one
more thing that they did.
So to keep going with this idea of
associating to different data types.
So they first fed this thing,
they first fed it, some associations
like Joe is a mother, a freer, you know,
Bob is a mother or a Ba.
Ba is a husband and Bert.
So a bunch of different associations. So
natural language, texts, associations.
Okay. And then once it had those
associations, 49 inputs later,
then you could say things like,
who is fray as maternal great uncle.
And because it's,
it's a graph problem.
It took this natural language and
it constructed a graph out of it,
then it's just a graph problem,
right?
You can just traverse the graph to find
who Frey as maternal great uncle is,
even though we didn't explicitly tell it,
who would that uncle was. Okay. So there,
it can do multiple things,
right? It's not just language,
it's also a graph construction. And the
fact that it's using an external, uh,
David structure for memory. It's such
a simple concept isn't it? I mean,
if you think about it, it's one of
those intuitive things like Duh,
like of course there should
be an external memory store,
but just no one tried it
before. I mean, you know,
we did have the dynamic memory
network out of Facebook.
We didn't have the neural Turing
machine by deep mine. But this is,
this is a really cool idea.
That's what I'm trying to say.
This is a really cool idea and
okay.
Yeah. So that's what they did.
And we've got an also neural networks.
Neural networks have memory,
right? They have memory,
but the memory is so interpolated
with the memory are the weights.
It's interpolated with the processing you.
But if we detach the memory
into a separate component,
that's when the results start
to get magical. And that's what,
that's what this is. Okay. Oh,
and here's the coolest part.
So the whole system is
differentiable. Okay. So the
whole thing is differentiable.
What do I mean by that? That means,
you know, when we differentiate or, uh,
back propagate our net, our
neural networks, we for propagate.
And then we take the difference
between the output and the prediction.
That's our error or loss.
And then we use that loss to compute the
partial derivative with respect to each
of the weights backwards.
And then we continually do that.
And that's how we update our network.
But, and that's how we differentiate.
But this whole thing is differentiable.
So it's not just the controller,
the network, but it's also
the, it's also the memory
memory store.
So this thing is differentiable too.
So will you compute the
partial derivatives with
respect to all of these rows in
memory? Okay. So there's
actually a lot of parts here.
And what we're gonna do is we're going
to go through each part, step by step,
and I'm going to talk about how each part
works. Okay. Uh, so get ready for this.
This is going to be up. This
is gonna be amazing. Okay.
You're going to have your mind blown.
So let's go,
let's go ahead and get started with
this. We have a lot to go over. Uh,
so it's gonna be a lot of fun.
The first thing that they did here.
So let me answer one of the questions.
One of the questions was how is
this different from its predecessor,
the neural Turing machine?
So there are several ways that in
here I in text how it's different.
Here's how it is different in text,
but there are several ways,
several ways that is different.
But basically it can all be summed up
as there are more memory access methods.
Okay. And so it's different
ways of interacting with memory.
So a more complex,
uh,
a more optimized way of
interacting with memory,
then the neural Turing machine and,
and it added this Tim temporal. I
loved the, I love the terminology here.
I love how deep mind
uses like a neuroscience
terminology because I mean they
have actual neuroscientists working on
their team but they added this temporal
link Matrix.
So you see these arrows pointing to
different arose in this memory bank or
memory matrix.
The reason that's there is so that they
so that they can so that the network can
know when it's reading or writing the
order with which things were written.
Re read or written to memory,
right.
It's the order and the order
helps because you know,
whether it's who is frail as
great uncles, paternal, whatever,
you want to know the order sometimes.
And so this adds an ordering to
the ReadWrite heads. Okay. So
right. Okay. So one more thing
before we start looking at the code.
Okay. I don't want to talk
about attention. So right.
So we have our controller,
we have our read and write heads and
then we have our memory bank. Okay.
So the question then is how do we
know where in this matrix to write to,
how do we know where in
this matrix to read too?
And the degree to which
we should do those things.
And that's where
attention comes into play.
We call it attention because
it's a way for us to frame how,
uh,
how precedents or how,
how important or how waiting is
played into how we read and write.
What do I mean by that?
How do we know where to store,
store to store stuff basically.
So they added three attention mechanisms.
The first one,
it's called content lookup.
So thinking about content address systems,
right?
When you have a content address
system, the, the key, uh,
the key each tells you what that content,
that content value is.
So it's the same thing with this.
We have a reader right head, okay.
And that's good. That's going to
contain some, you know, content address.
And then we have a similar
content address and memory.
And so what we do is then
we find the similarity,
the coastline similarity between all
the content addresses to see what's the
most similar.
And when we could use that,
that value that's the most similar to
then update our network, right? So,
so content look up via a
similarity measure is the first.
And we'll go through each of these uh,
attention mechanism. The second one, uh,
the second, uh, attention mechanism
is a temporal linking, right?
So how do we know the order that things
were re read and written to memory and
how do we then update our
network based on that?
And the third one is
allocating memory for writing.
So this is a dynamic
allocation for writing part.
Instead of having some static amount
of memory dedicated to writing,
we are dynamically allocating it.
So we're going to erase it and then,
and then rewrite,
rewrite over it dynamically.
You'll understand more
when we get to that part.
So there are three attention
mechanisms here. Okay.
And I love how they compared the
attention mechanisms to the hippocampal,
uh, ca three and one synapse synapse
regions of the brain, which is super cool.
And they also did this actually
recall from the, from the deep cue,
from deep cue, the, the network
that could beat all the,
of all those Atari Games
that use something else
from the hippocampal region.
It was called, what was it called,
experience replay, which uh,
came directly from neuroscience.
So deep minds papers read a lot like
new mantas except they actually pub.
They actually have great
results. So, oh yeah. Anyway,
so here we go. With this, let's get
to the code and also let me answer
two more questions before we
get to the code. Question one,
can we use this DNC for real
problems like data association?
Absolutely. Absolutely you can.
And they did, right? With the,
with the family members
in the family trees,
you can abstract that or
you can extrapolate that
problem to something entirely
different.
Like finding associations between
people,
obviously people,
but ideas and images and
different types of data,
different data types, numbers,
stuff like that. Yes, you can.
And then one more question,
can you explain the memory and
head operations in great details.
Still confused about it? Yes. Let me,
let me do that. As I go down
because that's, that's what this,
that's what the code is, right? The
details of that. But high level,
we have an external memory store,
right?
We have a neural network controller and
then we have an external memory store,
which is a matrix, right? It's a
matrix that we defined and you know,
x by y Matrix and we ever our neural
network and for our neural network we feed
it in an input. Okay. And it's
forward propagating. Right?
And then it's reading and writing
to memory. So it's saying,
so the degree to which we're reading
and writing is dependent on how we
structure it,
which we're going to go into.
But it's reading and
writing to memory too.
It's reading to see w just like it would
read its own weights just like it's,
it would read its own right weights.
It's reading from the memory store to
make predictions to compute that those,
that series of matrix operations that
it would to then output that that
prediction.
Right.
And it's writing for memory to then
just like it would write to its way.
It's right.
Just like how you multiply each weight by
each value as you propagate it forward.
You're also multiplying it by this memory,
this external memory,
a matrix,
and then we differentiate,
which is going to be awesome
when we get to it. Okay,
so let's get started with
the code from scratch.
We don't have time to just write it all
out because there's a lot of code and
there's a lot of theory here.
So we're going to focus on the theory.
We're going to focus on the
theory and then uh, we'll,
we'll compile it and run it and it's
going to be awesome. Okay, so, oh,
there's another question.
Is it better to have loops in neural
networks thing to go without it?
Is it better to have loops?
It's better if that's your use case.
What we're using in this in this
example is a feed forward network.
It's a feed forward network, uh, but
you could use a recurrent net. In fact,
in the paper they use a recurrent nets.
And when you would,
when would you want to use guys
helping answer this question?
When would you want to
use a recurrent network?
When would you want to have loops,
right?
When would you want to have the state
fed back into the input at the next time
step, when you have a sequence, okay?
When you have any kind of sequence,
any kind of sequential data, then you
would want a recurrent network, okay?
But the most simple type of
network is a feed forward net.
And that's what we're doing here
because we want to really, you know,
break it down to its bare essentials
so we can understand the general
architecture. And once we
understand the general architecture,
then we could use this for crazy new use
cases that no one has ever done before.
We are at the bleeding edge right now.
So let's, let's get started. Okay.
So we're going to define the DNC,
the differentiable neural computer as its
own class. Okay? And like all classes,
we want to initialize it in the,
in its function.
So let's go step by step through
what we're going to define here.
So the first thing we're going to define,
uh,
is the input data and the output data,
or the sizes of both.
Now this is what it's gonna look like.
Recall that it is a set
of pair of binary pairs,
one zero zero one zero zero
and these pairs are going
to be randomly initialized.
It doesn't matter,
but there's gonna be a mapping
both for the input and output data,
just a sets because they're both just
a series of ones and zeroes, right?
And we want to learn the mapping between
the two so that given some novel inputs
with ones and Zeros,
we can then predict what the probable
output set of ones and Zeros would be,
right? Because we already have a set of
them. It's a supervised learning problem.
And then we want to then predict
what that label would be.
So we have our inputs size and our output
size that we're going to define here.
Okay. And notice that these are coming
from the parameters up here, right?
We're going to define these when
we initialized our DNC later on.
But we're defining the class right now.
So that's the first part.
The next part is for us to define
our read and write vector size.
So notice how it's called numb words.
And words size.
But there are no words here,
right? This is kind of like,
like they had words in the deep mind code.
So this is kind of like leftover from
that. But there are no words here.
But what we can think of these two
variables as are the sizes of our read and
write vectors.
Because when we initialize them,
we'll be using these variables as,
as parameters to define the size
of our read and write vectors.
And a couple other variables that
will, that will, uh, talk about.
But they're basically these constant
values that we are going to use to,
to initialize a bunch of variables later
on. But their constant, these values,
these two values are constant, right?
The number of words and the word size.
In fact, we're going to use it to
initialize the size of our memory matrix.
Our memory matrix is going to be the
number of words by the word size.
That's the size of our memory
matrix. Okay. So then, uh,
we want to define our heads, right? So
how many heads do we want? And so that is,
so basically a head is an operation.
How many times,
how many times do we want to be reading
and writing to memory while we're
training our network?
And we're just going to say one,
we're going to have a single
head for every time step.
It's going to be reading and writing
to memory. Just one head. Okay,
so just to keep it simple, but we
could have multiple heads. Okay,
so then we're going to
define our interface size.
So what is this? So, oh,
so let me go back up here.
So I left out one part because
I wanted to get to it now.
So we have our inputs,
right?
We have our input data and then
we feed it to our controller.
It reads and writes and then it
and then outputs a prediction.
But a DNC doesn't just
output a prediction.
It also outputs a,
an interface vector.
And what the interface vector does is
it defines how we're going to interact
with the memory bank at the next time
step. So it's outputting, putting things,
it's out putting our prediction and
what's called an interface vector.
And we use this interface vector to
then feed it back into the network.
So then that the next time step, we know
how to interact with the memory bank.
So that's what we're doing here.
We're defining that the size
of that interface vector.
And yes,
there,
there are like three places in the
code where there are magic numbers.
And let me make sure that
you guys can see this.
So there are three places in the
code where there are magic numbers,
but,
but that's uh,
that's just how it is because I mean,
we could,
we could change these in our results would
be better. Uh, you know, I tried out,
I tried out several, several
numbers here, but these, these,
these produced the best convergence and
that's just all of deep learning, right?
For all hyper parameters.
But we're defining them by these,
remember these set a vector is this numb
words and word size that we're going to
consistently used throughout this, this
code. Okay. So we define our input data.
We define these two variables that will
help us initialize our memory matrix,
saw a length and width and then are
the number of heads we want to read and
write with the interface size,
which is the size of that output,
that associated vector with the output.
And then are then we're going
to define our input size,
which is the size of the input,
right? Which is going to be uh,
after we flatten it, what does that
size of that input going to be?
So we're going to define that here,
using those, those same two, uh,
parameters that we talked about before.
And then the output side,
what do we want the output size to be?
Well,
it's going to be the size of the
output that we defined earlier plus the
interface size,
cause it's one big vector that we could
split and then use later on. Okay.
And then we're going to define a,
a distribution on both outputs,
both the,
both the prediction and the interface.
So we have distributions around both.
And finally we create our memory
matrix. All right. Our memory matrix.
This thing up here, right over
here, it's just the matrix.
We can define it in one line of code. It's
just a matrix. It's not some, you know,
pseudo magical thing.
We'll define it as a set of Zeros using
our number of words by our word size,
but there are no words. It's just the
size versus the length versus width. Okay?
And Times W. Okay, we have
some more variables here.
So we've defined our matrix,
we defined a sides of our heads,
our input size or output size or you know,
input output heads and memory matrix size.
And now remember we don't just
have an external memory matrix.
We have a third matrix, right?
We have our neural network,
which we can consider one huge matrix.
We have our memory matrix,
but we also have this
third matrix over here,
which is this temporal linkage matrix,
right?
This is how we sequentially,
this is how whenever we're
reading and writing to memory,
we decide what order we should read and
write to the ordering matters, right?
Ordering definitely matters.
Whether it's a graph,
traversal problem or natural language
problem, the order matters because
we're going to continually
feed it data. Okay. So
right. So, okay,
so we have our usage vector and the
usage vector is going to record which
locations have been used so far.
So it's kind of like it's deciding where
in the memory bank have we are read and
written to before.
Then we'll store that there and we'll
use that usage vector to then define our,
our temporal link Matrix. Okay. Later on.
But right now we just initialize it with
Zeros and then we have our precedence.
Wait,
we're just going to represent the degree
to which the last location was written
to and the previous time step.
Once I get through up to this output,
wait right here,
then I'll answer questions.
Okay. So then, right,
so that's our Tempura
link Matrix essentially.
So we have what we've defined our major
components and now we've got to define
our, uh, read and write
head variables. Oh, right.
Head weights variables. I mean, let me
update that because we only have one head,
right?
But we have weights for that head right?
We have a set of read weights and a set
of right weights and these weights are
just matrices.
They're small matrices,
but they define the degree to which we're
reading and the degree to which we're
writing. It's what do I
mean by the degree to which,
well recall that reading and writing is
just, they're just matrix operations.
They're just multiplication and we
can define how much we're multiplying.
We can tune that similar to how we use
a learning rate when whenever we're
updating our weights, it's
like that. These weights,
these read and write weights define how
much we're multiplying the memory matrix
by, and remember the entire
thing is differentiable.
So everything is updated,
right? You might be,
because you might be wondering how do
we know what the read wage should be or
what the right way it should be,
or even what the usage weight
or the link matrix should be.
We're differentiating everything based
on the output that the loss between the
output and the, uh, the predicted
output in the actual outputs.
And we're using that to differentiate
the entire thing. All the components,
which is amazing.
If you think about it,
it's an end to end system
end to end differentiable.
So we have a read weights are right
weights and then our read vectors,
which are going to use the right
read weights to then apply that.
That's what we actually do.
The Matrix multiplication with we take
our weights times are vectors and then
that's how we get our,
uh,
okay.
That's how we get our output
for the, for the Matrix. Okay.
So then we've got our
uh, placeholders, right?
These are our tension flow placeholders.
We're going to feed in our input and
output pair, right? Those ones and Zeros,
both of them are gateways and we just
feed them both in learning the mapping and
then predicted output. Okay.
So then we define our networks.
So because this is a super simple use
case, we have one read head. Okay.
We have just binary input output pairs.
Let's just define a feed forward to
layer feed forward network, right?
It's got set of weights and set of
biases. So weight bias, weight bias. Nope,
that's it. Okay. Uh, let me make
sure that we can see everything here.
Okay.
Okay. This is a little longer line.
So let me, let me go over here.
Float 32 we've named our, you
know, standard deviation of 0.1.
We defined the size by
using the input size. Okay,
so this part's going to be cut off here
as well, but just recognize that it's,
it's similar. Okay. So let me
make it bigger again. Okay.
So where was I? So, okay,
so we divide our network and let me,
let me talk about these and
then I'll answer questions.
So then we have our output weights. So
we have weights for our output, right?
So all of these components have
weights. Are, are our output,
our output values have weights,
spoke the interface factor and the output.
And why do they have weights so that
we can then differentiate. We don't,
we don't,
uh,
we take the partial derivative
with respect to not just
our controllers weights,
but by the weights up our outputs,
by the weights of our heads,
by the weights of our Matrix,
uh,
and by the weights of
our Tempura link Matrix.
So we take the partial derivative
with respect to everything.
So even the weights, even the
outputs have weights. Okay.
Both the and we and we initialize them
randomly using this TF truncated normal
function. Okay. And then we
also have a read vectors output.
Wait. Okay. So now let me answer some
questions because now we can get to the,
the fun part.
So the questions are,
let me just see who's, who's who.
Okay. We've got 408 people here.
All right. People are doing good. Okay.
Is it better to have loops in neural
networks then too? No, no, no.
I already answered that.
Can you tell me what is the difference
between fine tuning and transfer learning?
Transfer learning.
Okay.
Okay. So fine tuning is a, is a kind
of vague term. You could think of.
Transfer learning as fine tuning.
In fact you could think of all machine
learning is fine tuning. We are,
we are iteratively improving our model.
But transfer learning is when you
train a network on some task. Okay.
And then you used that pretrained
model to then learn from my different,
try a different tasks.
So you're transferring the
learnings from one task to another.
Two more questions. What if the Matrix is
larger than the amount of Ram you have.
So that
would probably not happen unless
you have a really, uh, both, uh,
really bad computer and the model is huge,
like gigantic. Uh, but if that
happened, then you would have a,
an overflow or ramp up your, uh,
an overflow for, of Ram and your,
and your computer. Your system
would notify you of that with a,
with a pop up unless it was like,
I dunno Debbie and or something
would and in which case you're just,
you're screwed.
Okay.
So then do you guys use radial basis
functions as kernels in neural networks?
So I haven't seen those used a lot.
Uh,
those are rarely used.
I see it. I can recall.
Radial basis function is being used in
uh,
mark off chains. So like
Markov models. I see.
Those used with those is mid is mid I
data a sequence of data that can be fed
into a looping neural network. I'm
trying to create a mid I generator. Yes.
I've got like three videos on that.
Generate music intenser flow,
how to build an AI composer and how
to generate music and tensorflow live.
Check out all of the videos.
Okay, so back to this back.
Back in black. Okay, so
we define all of our,
all we did was we just defined all of
our vectors that we're going to be using,
right? All of our, all of our components,
we defined our components of
this thing but the country. Okay?
So that would be the controller,
the,
the weights for the output and the
weights for the interface vector. The,
the read, the, the one head
that we're using in the waits
for it, the memory bank,
which is a memory matrix that the
tempura link Matrix and it's associated
weights.
That's it.
Okay.
That's what we just defined.
And now we're going to actually,
uh,
go right into the step function.
So,
so notice how I've got
two functions up here.
Each of these is for a
different attention mechanism.
So we have three attention mechanisms
for the network for the controller to
decide how we're going to
deal with this memory bank,
how we're going to update this
memory bank. And read from it. Uh,
but let's go straight into the step
function and then we'll talk about the
details of these helper functions. So
we'll start at a high level and then go,
uh,
increasingly a more low level.
So
here's what happens. The step function
happens at every time step, right?
So whenever we build
our session at the end,
we're going to run this step function
continuously. So at every time step,
the controller receives an input vector
from the Dataset and emits an output
vector,
but it also receives a set of read vectors
from the memory matrix at a previous
time step via the read heads.
Okay?
Then it emits an interface vector that
defines its interaction with the memory
at the current time step.
So now I'm going to add something else on.
This is notice I'm adding things on, uh,
iteratively. So remember how I said, Oh,
you have one input and you have one
output. And then I was like, actually,
you have one input and
then you have two outputs.
One output is the predicted output and
the other output is an interface vector
that defines how you interact with the
memory bank. And the next time set,
well we've actually not just got
two outputs. We've got two inputs.
So one of the inputs is the data itself,
but the other input is going to be
the
read vector from the previous time step.
So think about this for a second.
This is not a recurrent network.
We're using a feed forward network but
because we're not feeding in the state of
the controller from a previous time step,
but what we are feeding from a
previous time step is the read vector.
So it's a feed forward network but so
the controller is feed forward but as a
whole there is recurrence happening.
So you could think of the differential
neural computer as a whole,
as a recurrent network but not in the
traditional sense or feeding in the
previous state of the network
to the previous time step.
But in the sense that we are feeding in
the read vector from the previous times
that from the memory matrix, from the
external memory store back into the input.
So in that way it's recurrent. Okay. So,
so that's what's happening
at every time step.
It receives an input vector
from the dataset and missing
an output vector and an
interface vector. And then at the next
time seven and puts the next, the,
the next input is going to be from
the Dataset and the read vector.
And then we just repeat that over and over
again. So let's, let's do this. Let's,
let's programmatically go
through what this looks like.
So the first step is first is for us to
reshape our input so that it's, it's,
it's fit for the size of our network,
right?
So we've got our input data and remember,
uh,
we also have the read vectors,
right? Both of those things.
We've got our input and they're read
vectors from the previous time step.
And then we take that input and then we
forward propagate through the network.
We forward propagate through the
network and in remember it's a two layer
network,
right?
So we do a matrix multiplication by
the weights and biases Tan h as our
activation function matrix
multiplication 10 age.
And this l two activation is going to
be our output. Okay. Um, well, sorry.
No, no, no. Sorry.
This is going to be our output and we're
going to use that last activation to
compute it by then doing
matrix multiplication. But
this is our output vector.
And then this is going to
be our interface vector.
So remember there are two outputs,
the both a normal output and
the interface vector. Okay.
So now we have both of our outputs.
We forward propagated and it's time to
then use these two vectors to then learn
and do more, more things with. Okay.
So then we've got this one line.
So remember I said how there's magic
numbers in three parts of this code?
We talked about that one. This is
the other part. So the partition,
what the F is this?
So the partition is a,
it's what we're going to use to define
our interaction with the memory matrix.
Okay. So we take this partition
and it's a, it's a 10,
it's a, it's a, it's think of it as a
list or an array with 10 parts to it.
And it's just one big, uh, one big
matrix that we're then going to
that were there aren't
going to convert into a,
a set of keys and a set of
strings and a set of vectors.
Okay. So let me go ahead and, uh,
talk about how we're going to split
these up into a set of keys and vectors.
All right. But first, let me answer
some questions before we get into this.
So in terms of questions we've got,
can we use neural nets to make something
like a PCB layout designer because
currently available
ones are crap. Ah, yes.
How would you do that?
You would want to use a generative model?
Uh, probably a generative
adversarial network. Train it on.
Now, I'm not, I'm not familiar with
the components of how a PCB works,
but I assume that you can think of it
as a graph problem as well because you
have different components and data is
flowing through the hardware in a certain
way or you know, it's some kind of
mapping. But think of it as a graph,
traversal problem and you're feeding it
all these graphs and it's supervised,
right? And you have the correct
paths for all of these examples.
And then given these set of examples,
you can then generate a new path which
would then be a new PCB layout design.
That's just one way. But yes, you
could for sure. Okay, so back to this.
So we want to convert our interface vector
into a set of readings factors and we
use the partition to do that. Okay. So
what do I mean by the partition? Let me,
let me back up here for a second. Let me
back up. Let's back up. Let's back up.
We have our controller and it outputs
to things it outputs are output vector,
which is our prediction. And the
outputs are interface vector. Okay.
And our interface vector is meant for our
network to then decide how to interact
with the memory bank at the next
time step. But how do we know?
So how do we know exactly how to
interact with the memory bank? Well,
we're gonna use this partition and what
the partition does is it defines sizes
for 10 different.
Think of these as placeholders.
What these 10 placeholders
are going to be,
or they're going to become
these 10 variables right here.
They're going to become
these 10 variables.
So before we initialize these variables,
we define the sizes of them.
And what these variables are going
to do is they're going to be,
they're going to come out
of the interface vector.
So think of the interface sector as one
big matrix or one big vector, same thing.
And then we use the partition to then
split that vector and two sizes that we've
predefined beforehand.
And each of those is going to be a a V
and an important component that we're
going to then use to update our memory
bank. So we have our interface vector,
we define a partition to split it up
into a set of sizes that we want and then
we dynamically partition it using tfs
dynamic partition function into the read
key into three read variables,
three right variables and then three
gate variables which I haven't talked
about, which we will. And then I
read a set of read modes. So there,
there are quite a few
parts here. Okay. So,
so once we have these variables
then we can define what the Sh,
what the shape and size of them are.
So we've initialize them as parts of the
interface vector because we're going to
then update our memory bank using these.
So we have our set of read vectors
and our set of right vectors.
So the keys defined where we want to,
we will, we'll use the keys
to find a similarity between
whatever we have in our,
our memory bank too so that we could
then read from it whatever is the most
similar or maybe it's whatever is the
least similar that's that's up for it to
learn with its own weights.
Right.
It depends on the use case
and that's up for it to learn.
A lot of these things like you
might be asking, well why, uh,
why does it choose one place or the other?
That's all dependent on the data,
right? It learns how to interact
with it. We're just defining the,
the blueprint here.
We're defining a blueprint and then it's
going to learn how to interact with the
memory matrix, but we can
definitely improve the, uh,
the blueprint. So, so the key
is going to be like, you know,
it's like for a dictionary, it's, it's,
it's the content address and
then the string is going to be,
it's going to help us initialize
our read weights. Okay.
This is str is going to help.
This value is going to help us initialize
our read waits for a right factors.
It's the same thing we have, our
key string is going to help us, uh,
initialize our weights.
And then we have two vectors here.
There are two components to writing.
First we erase and then we write.
So it's like an override.
So if before we write to something,
we wouldn't erase what's already there.
And then right over that empty space.
Okay.
And
yeah,
and so then we initialize these using
the sigmoid function and then the soft
plus, which is another, uh,
yeah,
which is another probability function.
Okay.
So then we have a read vectors
in our right vectors that we,
we've created from our interface factor,
which was one of our two outputs.
And now we're going to define our gates.
So what are these?
So recall from LSTM networks
from gru networks, we had gates.
Now these gates are just ski scalar
values. They're just single numbers.
But we call them gates
because they define,
they define the degree to which we,
we perform a certain operation.
So remember LSTM networks had, forget
it had each LSTM cell has a forget gate.
Okay. And it had two other dates and
then a gru unit has a update gate.
It's got to reset gate and
these gates to find that the,
the degree to which we are
performing these operations,
whether it be reset or
update and it's differential.
Those were differentiable too.
So recall we,
whenever we differentiated
our LSTM network,
we updated those gate values and so then
it read and erased and in Erie or wrote
as it as necessary as it
as it would best converge.
So it was up to it to learn what
these gate values should be.
Everything is learned, the right
vectors, the, the gates, the keys,
all of it is learned through
differentiation through backpropagation.
Okay. We're just the
beautiful architecture that
everything is, is, is learned.
We don't define anything
sadequee except for those,
those two lines of magic numbers
that I, that I showed you guys. Okay.
So then we have three gates.
The first one is the free gate,
which defines the degree to
which locations that read
heads will be freed. Okay.
Then the allocate,
which is the fraction of writing that
as being allocated to in a new location
and then the right than the right gate.
The amount of information
to be written to memory.
So how much do we want to write to memory?
So we, so we have one gate for reading,
one gate for writing and then one
gate for dynamic memory allocation.
So at every time step we,
we are deciding how much memory do want
to allocate to some, to some head value,
whether it be a read or a right. It's
not some static dynamic. You know,
a static allocation is dynamic. It
changes at every time step. Okay.
So then we have one more uh,
variable from our partition that
we talked about at the very end.
What was that last one? It was the read
modes. So what are these read modes?
The read heads can use gates called
read modes to switch between content,
look up using a read key and reading out
locations either forwards or backwards
in the order they were written.
So the mode is,
it tells us how we should
read. Okay. So it's like,
it's an addition to the read weights
that helps define should we read in a
forward direction or backward direction.
And it again,
this thing learns how to do
that. We just defined that, hey,
there should be a direction
with word reading,
create some differentiable value that we
can then learn to update via training.
Okay.
And then so we've defined
that and now we're going to,
when I said we're going to dynamically
allocate memory, this is what I mean,
the usage Vectra is, is, is what, what is,
what's going to help us
dynamically allocate memory.
So we have a retention vector,
which is this,
which is the helper vector
for the usage factor.
But the retention vector is used to
calculate the usage vector and it's asking
us what's available to write to,
okay, what is available to write too.
So then,
uh,
we can then write to it. So let
me go back for a second. Let me,
let me do a little high level refresher.
We had our input,
we Ford propagated it through
the network and then we computed,
our output vector is both the predicted
output and the interface vector.
And then we can,
and then we partition that interface
vector using this partition,
a variable and the dynamic partition
function and to a set of parameters with
which we can then interact with our memory
bank at the next time step. We then,
uh, initialized and flattened and resized
all the reading right vectors and the
gates, which the regionwide white
vectors. And then the gates,
which controls the degree to which we're
reading and writing as well as the read
modes,
which is the direction that we're reading.
And now we're going to actually perform
the read and writing both the reading
and the writing. Okay, so for the,
so we're going to start
off with performing the
writing and then we'll do the
reading. Okay, so now let me, let me write
that out. So we're going to rights first.
So now we're going to actually
do the writing and reading.
We define all of our variables.
Now it's time to actually do the writing.
So for the writing will
compute our usage vector,
which we'll use to
dynamically allocate memory.
And then we're going to define our set
of right to waits for the right head.
So retrieved the writing allocation
waiting. Okay. And then we just,
we decided where to write to and then we
can define our right weights using both
of those variables,
both the allocate,
allocate weights and
the alloc allocate gate.
And that's going to give
us our right weights,
how much space to allocate for
them and where to write too,
like how much space to dedicate
to writing and where to write too.
And then then we can update our right
to our memory matrix using that.
So first we recall we first
erase using this erase vector,
then we right. And both
of these operations occur
through matrix multiplication.
First we erase, then we right.
And that's it for writing.
Okay,
now we're going to read.
So we writ rewrote first and now
we're going to read. So for reading
and guys if you sit through
this, I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm going
to wrap at the end. So, so,
so get ready for this and we're almost
done. So I'm going to answer questions.
Okay. I know there's a lot of
parts to this, but it's, it's,
it's an amazing architecture and it's
definitely worth looking into. It's,
it's an amazing architecture.
Okay.
So we've written to our memory matrix
and now we're going to read from it.
So as well as writing,
the controller can read from multiple
locations and memory memory can be
searched based on the content of each
location using content lookup or the
associated tempura links can be followed
backwards and forwards to recall
information written in
sequence or reverse,
which is our third attention mechanism.
Now I haven't,
I haven't actually talked about our, uh,
attention mechanisms yet, but let me,
this is going to be our
first, which is, uh,
which is recalling memory using
our tempura links, which is that,
remember that Matrix of, of arrows
right up here. That's going to be our,
that's essentially an attention
mechanism. Like how do we, uh,
we didn't write to memory based
on what's happened before. Okay.
So we'll define our link matrix,
which is that those,
those sets of arrows,
that third matrix,
that the third big matrix
I talked about using, uh,
though the weight factor that we defined
here at using our right are right with
vape weights. Okay. And so then
we'll use the link matrix and our right
weights to define our precedence weights
and our precedents weight
is going to help us
with our,
let's see what else.
Okay,
so then are precedents,
wait,
so we don't actually,
okay, so we, so the precedents waste,
which was used to create the link Matrix
and then we updated it right here.
So we just updated it like we've,
we've used it to define our link Matrix
and now we can just update it. Okay.
And so let me make sure you
guys can see this. Okay.
So now we're going to define our three
modes. Remember our read modes forward,
backward and content.
Look up by using matrix multiplication on,
on our read weights. Okay. Uh, for,
for three modes and these
are all differentiable,
all the modes are differentiable.
And
for lookup we're going to diff, we're
going to initialize it using content,
look up.
And then we're going to,
now we can initialize our read
weights using those three modes.
And then we'll create our read vector
using the redx weights and the memory
matrix.
And then we multiply it together to get
a read or read vector and then we can
return it as the sum of our
outputs and what we just,
uh,
calculated that product value that which
is what we've now read from memory and
we feed it back into the
next time step. Right? Okay.
And so what this, what this function
right here is this run function is,
is it's essentially just,
uh,
creating the outputs for,
for each of the inputs using unstack
a sequence of outputs. So this,
this just generates are, are,
are associated output sequence. So
a small little helper function. Uh,
but okay. So also, let me go back and
now let me define the other two, uh,
attention mechanism. So we talked
about one of the attention mechanisms,
which was the, uh, Tempura linkage, right?
How do we define the order with which
we are updating our memory bank?
But there are two more
attention mechanisms here.
The first one is content
lookup, right? So remember it's,
it's kind of like recommendation
systems. It's kind of like, you know, uh,
word vectors where we are finding
the distance between two vectors.
We're doing that with our
controller and our memory bank.
So whenever we're reading from, uh, our
memory bank where we have a vector here,
right, the, the read wait vector.
And then we have our vectors,
which are all the rows in the memory bank.
And we want to find a similarity between
all of them and then find the one that
is either the most similar or the least
similar and it's up to it to learn what
like level of,
of similarity it needs to then read from
it learns where to read from using this
content.
Look up attention mechanism.
So we find the l two norm of using the
key. So let me, let me read this out.
A key vector emitted by the controller
is compared to the content of each
location in memory according
to a similarity measure.
The similarity score is determined,
a weighting that can be used by the heads
for associative recall or by the right
head to modify an existing vector
in memory. So we have a key, uh,
Riki and we then compute the l two norm,
which is a way of normalizing of vector.
It's a standard formula
for normalizing a vector.
It's a square root of the sum
of the absolute values squared.
So if we take all of the components
of a vector, square them,
and then square root it,
and that's going to be r a l two norm.
And we'll do that for both
the memory matrix and the key.
And then we'll perform a
matrix multiplication to
compute these similarity.
And then we'll squash it with
a soft Max and return that.
And that's gonna give
us a probability value.
That is a percentage of how similar
the key is to to the memory matrix.
So that's, that's one, that's
our second attention mechanism.
And then our third attention mechanism
is the actual dynamic allocation of
memory as we, as we train
this model. So how do we,
so basically what this does is it
retrieves the writing allocation weighting
based on the usage free list.
So which is the usage of vector and the
usage of each location is represented as
a number between zero and one and a
weighting that picks out unused locations.
It's delivered to the right head,
it's independent of the size.
And the contents of the men memory.
So that means that you can use a on,
you can use a DNC,
this DNC on a task where using one size
of memory and later you can upgrade to a
larger memory. So it's independent of
sizes. See the only parameter for it,
his self that we're not
telling it well you should be,
you should allocate memory
of this size of exercise.
It decides that for itself and it
can be arbitrarily big or small.
Theoretically it could
be infinity. Okay. So
we are then taking the sorted
usage vector. We're going
to sort the usage vector,
uh, uh, sending lea,
and then we're going to compute the
cumulative product of all of those
components.
And then for,
and then you and then initialize our
allocation weights using those values.
And then for each of our use of vectors,
we're going to flatten it and then add
it to the weight matrix and return the
allocation waiting for each row in memory.
This is essentially a matrix of allocation
values that we can then use to decide
how best we want to allocate memory.
So it's a matrix that we were
returning from this. Okay, so that's,
those are our three attention mechanisms.
I know it's a lot to take in,
but those are our three
attention mechanisms.
And now let's get to our main function
and we'll talk about how we can actually
use this. We, we've defined everything,
we didn't find our attention mechanisms,
our parameters are hyper parameters are
components of our differential neural
computer and now it's time for us
to actually train this, this thing.
So we'll start off by defining these
parameters and these parameters are going
to be used, are going to be used to
initialize our data randomly, right?
This random dot ran into is going to
initialize our input data and our output
data, which are a set of binary
numbers ones and Zeros. Okay?
So now we'll go ahead and initialize
or tensor flow session initialize a
differentiable and your old
computer and then run it.
And the run function is then going
to compute the output. It's gonna,
it's gonna run this step function seat
that we defined this huge step function.
It's going to at every time step for a
number of iterations we want and it's
going to output the, you know, whatever
that output's going to be like one zero,
zero, zero like that. That's
going to be the output.
And then once we have our predicted
output and we have our expected output,
we then want to compute
the loss between those.
And we'll do that with a dis
sigmoid cross entropy function.
And that's gonna give us our loss then.
And this is use case dependent,
we don't always have to do this,
but we're doing it right now.
We're going to regularize
each layer of our controller.
And what regularization does is it can
improve convergence sometimes. Okay.
And we'll use the l two loss to do that,
which is similar to the l two norm.
And then once we have that we'll add
the regular risers in and then we'll
optimize it using Adam,
which is grading dissent.
And so when we do gradient descent,
it's being applied to the controller,
the memory bank,
their head,
the three attention mechanisms and
the team portal linkage matrix.
Everything is, is, is differentiable.
And once we've done that,
we can initialize all of our variables
and then initialize our input and output
data using the,
The v the variables we defined right up
here that I talked about right up here.
And then for each iteration
we're going to feed in the pair,
each input output pairings,
your feed dect and then run our session
using our loss optimizer and output and
then feeding in our input and outputs.
And that's going to give us our results.
And let me run this again,
which is the code, but in it's,
it's in a,
I literally just took this from a,
a python file and then paste
it into a Jupiter notebook.
So let me do it from,
from command line,
which is a python DNC to pot.
Nope,
both on TNC dot pie.
Okay.
Bunch of warnings because we've
got a lot of, uh, you know, things,
a lot of deprecations happening.
Okay.
So
I just want to see what everyone's
saying here. Okay, great.
I know I should write a book.
I did write a book,
it's called decentralized applications.
I'll probably write a book later,
but I've got to do a lot of other
things first. So, uh, other questions.
Can we run DNC on calming home
PC? Yes, you can. If you have a,
any kind of computer, you can run this
thing because look at this. I mean this,
this is just binary scalar values.
I mean,
you don't need a Gpu for this.
You just need to CPU and
any kind of numerical data
you can run easily on a CPU,
on a home PC. But if you want to start
applying this to graph traversal problems,
like deep minded, like solving
the, the London Underground,
like the shortest path,
uh, then you need a Gpu. But you
could still do this on a home PC.
You don't need a cluster for this one.
Would you need a cluster?
If you are applying this to natural
language, then you need a cluster.
If you're applying this, if you want
to create a question answering system,
then you want to, you do this in
the cloud. Okay. Using, uh, using,
I have a video on that coming out in
two days. So I'll, I'll tell you guys,
use Floyd hub use Floyd hub. Okay. But I
have, I have a video coming out on that.
Okay. So on cloud options. Okay.
So we've got two minutes and I'm going
to spend the rest of this session
answering questions for the
last two minutes. But, uh,
I also want to play this in the
background because it's, it's cool. Okay.
This is what you can
do, right? Associations,
associations between unrelated datasets,
whether the beat language,
natural language or graph traversal or
image recognition or speech recognition
or speech generation or audio generation
or graphics generation or you know,
all sorts of different domains can be
learned if we have an external memory
memory store that acts as the blueprint
to then create these learning systems,
these neural networks.
So we separate the processing from the
memory and we have results that make our
hearts sing. So for the last
set of questions we have here,
uh,
do you know if they invited people for
the Ai Nanodegree I don't know. Uh, and
live stream next week.
So this is the last livestream for awhile.
I've been doing live streams for the past
17 weeks and it's been super fun. Uh,
this is a Ted talk and,
uh,
instead I'm going to be doing
something similar. It's,
it's going to be a prerecorded version
of like me, you know, typing out stuff.
It's not going to be live at
least for a while. Uh, and yeah,
you're still going to get
amazing content like this.
It's just not always going to be live.
Uh, I will do lives again in the future.
Don't worry. I know. It's not like I'm
stopping my lives and, uh, yeah. So,
but this is,
this is this differentiable
neural computer is the future.
This is this idea of separating
processing and memory is the future. Okay.
Let me, let me wrap as well to, to the
sa out. So just throw on a beat and um,
I'll wrap about something.
Okay.
Thank you guys for staying through
the session. You guys are heroes.
I'm very proud of you
for staying through this.
This is nontrivial and the fact
that you stayed through this,
it makes me very proud of you and very
proud to be a part of this community that
we are all in together. So whenever
you guys are ready, go ahead and, uh,
play that beat.
How much data does this
need? It depends. Uh,
it depends, uh, how much data
it needs on what your use cases.
Oh, I definitely need you guys. Okay.
I'm going to keep having livestreams.
Don't worry about it. Uh, just, just not
the, you know, current time being. Okay.
I love the DNC.
I try to do it like I want to be me.
I don't care about all these models.
You see,
I only want to use something that takes
three different data sets and put them
together. You see, look, I take
a one die. You didn't converge.
The beat stops, but it doesn't
matter, man. I'm like, I splurge.
I burst out into the
world like on the king.
Don't stop and look at
on machine learning mat.
It's like being the worst service
ever created by Microsoft. Oh, I just,
this Microsoft man, don't
look before I get shot. Okay,
so that's the wrap. All right. So
thank you guys for showing up for now.
I've got to go create some,
some more amazing content for you guys.
Thank you for showing up. I love you
guys and cool. Thanks for watching. Huh?